einzusehen die zeugnis abgeben wie alles
begann im reich der mitte
man weiß nicht wie er ausgesehen hat der
mann der sich selbst zum ersten kaiser
von china ausrief zum 10
immerhin haben ihm zahlreiche filme ein
gesicht gegeben
häufig wird er als grimmiger krieger
dargestellt
der als selbstherrlicher disput auftrat
und den blutigen schlachten seinen
nachbarstaaten unterwarf
sein imperium war eines der größten
seiner zeit
von giovanni ist bis heute in china weit
mehr erhalten geblieben als seine
terrakotta armee
und es hat ihn sicher bedeutend gemacht
dass er das transportwesen die schrift
die
große mauer und ähnliche projekte in
angriff genommen hat die zu einem
zusammenhalt dieses riesenreiches
geführt haben und zu sagen sich
abgrenzen nach außen letztendlich zu
einem nationalen bewusstsein dessen was
chinesisch betreut
der fund der terrakotta armee war 1974
eine archäologische sensation
nun ist ein krieger truppe im
historischen museum in berlin angekommen
diese infanteristen und offiziere haben
den ersten kaiser in den tod begleitet
sie gehören zu einem 8000 köpfigen
tönernen her
ein teil einer gewaltigen grabanlage die
das alte ägypten mit seinen pyramiden in
den schatten stellt
der armee verdankte jinchuan die seine
macht
sie war die schlagkräftigste seinerzeit
das ideale machtinstrument für den sohn
des himmels der trieb unbeirrt seine
größenwahnsinnigen projekte voran
700.000 zwangsarbeiter bauten an seinem
mausoleum
überlebende wurden später eingemauert
um widersacher einzuschüchtern ließ der
kaiser die bevölkerung ganzer
landstriche exekutiert
selbst überlebte er mehrere attentate
ein scheusal ohnegleichen und dennoch
filmheld im heutigen china es gibt wenn
wir gerade in diese staatstragenden
filme schauen natürlich schon die
positionierung treasuries als einem
national einiger und man kann sehen wie
das immer passiert ist wenn in china in
krisen war wenn china das gefühl hatte
hier könnte etwas auseinander brechen
gibt es zentrifugalkräfte die dieses
riesenreich bedrohen das benzinsparen
die wieder aus der graphischen
mottenkiste herausgekramt worden ist um
ein statement zu machen der mann der
schiene erschuf jede epoche sieht ihn
anders den einen gilt als übervater
den anderen als schreckensbild
ein mythos der niemals still
kosten sie noch einmal auf die
dimensionen hier auf dem rollfeld in
dübendorf